Okay, so we have 2 polynomials that we
are trying to add together. And this may
sound silly, but if we're adding one
quantity to another, we're actually adding
+1 times this quantity. Anything,
let's say some number a, times 1 is
just equal to itself. So a times 1 is a,
and 5 times 1 is 5, and 4x^2 times 1 is 4x^2,
and -2x times 1 is-2x.
So having the parentheses here with the
plus sign in front of them doesn't change
the value or the sign of any of the terms
inside the second set of parenthesis. So
we can just write it but without the
parenthesis. There's also nothing
happening to the first set of parenthesis,
at least not yet, so we can just rewrite
it without the parenthesis as well. And
now, we have a thing that we have a ton of
practice we're dealing with. We just need
to rearrange our terms and simplify. Once
we've rearranged we combine our now
adjacent like terms. So for x^2 term we
have 11x^2.
And now I'm dealing with the x to the
first terms, +2 -2 is just zero, so these
cancel each other out. And we don't have
any term in the final answer with an x^1
in it. Then we just have 1+4 so our final
answer is 11x^2+5.
I just love doing these problems so much.
because you start out with something
that's so complicated and messy looking,
and you end up with a really, really
beautiful simple answer.